I think Latin America is in front of
significant challenge for the years to
come first are a consolidation of
democracy which is right now under
significant risks given a lot of
populism and centralization and totally
tourism and on the second and we also
have a challenge of consolidating
institutions strong institutional Latin
America has also challenges on improving
standards of living closing the gaps
between rich and poor and generating a
high standards of wealth health of
housing and basic services and education
on the same side on the other side I
think that Latin America has huge
opportunity in the years to come the
possibility to to tackle a huge amount
of resources that are across the region
and at the same time the possibility to
exploit in environmentally friendly way
the past territories that served for
agriculture and food production and I
think that's a great opportunity for
Latin America in the yeast